[Musique]
voir les amis bon c'est pas trop ça sera
au repos
il y a quelqu'un qui prépare de la bonne
cuisine je te seront vite pas trop
j'espère bien que c'est pas preneur ou
nicolas l'europe
bon le fun au nikaïa tu arrêter de faire
des trous dans mon papa mais bon prono
c'est pâques ou pas je regarde où sous l
eau ça sent bon tu vois tu apprenais
l'effet de la pâtisserie heureusement
petit pâtissier ou les choses maintenant
[Musique]
c'est délicieux et moi le jeu ne pas ne
touchez pas menin et des mois plus tôt à
mettre les fruits sur la table
voilà ce que les belles cette tarte aux
fruits
encore un petit peu de sucre y petit
bourbon et voilà ça cuit et maintenant
nous allons faire un gros bacs pour le
nours juste aux bobos ça se bourrer les
20 20
[Musique]
mais madeleine les coquins les fils a
essayé de recommencer vous allez voir
votre papa preneur nous allons tout
comme quoi on veut te tais pas prenez le
bon alors toi de bourse du femmes
mélangés ma famille là et toi échos la
caisse à nous allons battre déçu voilà
très calmes in motion
[Musique]
batman tas de planches
j'ai du mal à nos nombreux cas assez
bien mélanger que plusieurs des banana
ne vous fâchez pas nous ferons un baba
la prochaine fois
voyons voir la tartaprônes elle je la
sors tu fous ici et voilà la super bravo
pas preneur attention nicolas c'est très
chaud tu es une très bonne pratique
heures
apprenez à lons les enfants on laisse
refroidir la tarte ou la mange rue top
et on va l'y
[Musique]
boonen il n'est plus
non j'étais fait pour eux time line of
adz m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre petit pimprenelle fait de très
bons gâteaux lustres ont deux messieurs
patron et bien nounours tu met de la
poudre à présent ce n'est pas de la
poudre aux se doit alors en route mon
gros nounours donner des petits allez
vite vous coucher un dogme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]